hola buenas tardes a todos gracias a la
organización y todos los asistentes
cuando me preguntan cómo me tomé el
diagnóstico de la lesión
no voy a engañar digo que mal cuando te
dicen que no puedes hacer lo que más te
gusta que no puede seguir con tu pasión
te enfadas y te pones triste pero por
suerte me duró sólo un mes y a día de
hoy puedo decir que la lesión me ha
abierto y abierto las puertas del azkena
cerrado
os voy a contar un poquito sobre el
deporte que practico pues alguien no lo
conoce y luego voy a hablar un poquito
de mi vida y lo que ha supuesto para mí
la práctica deportiva
en karate que es el deporte que practico
estando en realidad es la modalidad de
kumite que es el combate que todo el
mundo conoce donde se ponen las
protecciones y uno frente al otro te
lean lean sin contacto excesivo y la
madera de cata los catas son movimientos
preestablecidos contra contrincantes
imaginarios en el vídeo que es esta que
estoy poniendo se ve ellos tienen un
momento ya que hacer y en lo que los
jueces valoran velocidad fuerza
equilibrio concentración y en mi caso
que es el carácter en silla de ruedas
también se valoran elementos de
dificultad como puede ser hacer un
caballito hacer un giro de 360 grados
en caballito o ponerla así a una rueda
dicho esto empezamos
la niña chiquitita que sale en la
primera foto soy yo y nací dando guerra
nací con una hernia inguinal sin más
sintomatología que llorar llorar llorar
y llorar
los médicos decían que eran gases me
dieron de todo para los gases
hasta que con seis meses en la sala de
espera del pediatra vomité kaká
normal que me acuerdo
eso fue lo que decidió la luz de alerta
y decidieron que tenían que ver qué me
pasaba me trasladaron de desde niña del
campo hasta madrid al niño jesús donde
llegué con una obstrucción intestinal
bastante grave por suerte
pero cogieron a tiempo y me salvaron la
vida esos seis meses mi madre se los
paso conmigo en el sofá todas las noches
sin dormir gracias mamá
y seguir creciendo sin ningún tipo de
problema con 8 años mi padre es militar
y nos destinaron le decían a toledo
y aquí nos venimos toda la familia
con cuatro años en medina del campo
donde nací empecé a practicar karate es
un deporte que me enamoró me enamoró esa
modalidad y me enamoró de todos los
deportes
con 12 o 13 años empecé a competir en la
modalidad de kumite
no sé nada del todo mal
condiciones provinciales y regionales
siempre subía al podium y decidieron
llevarme a los campeonatos de españa
en el año 2005 que de tercera de españa
individual en mi categoría
y en el año 2006 quedamos terceros por
equipos
el 2006 fue
fue mi último año de
la competición de pie
un día entrenando un compañero me dio
una patada en la rodilla y me lanzo
los médicos decían que era una lesión
grave que me podía permitir seguir
haciendo vida normal pero no competir al
nivel que estaba compitiendo
fue una de las decisiones
más difíciles y más duras para mí a
nivel deportivo dejar la competición
lo que me obligó también a desvincular
me un poquito del kárate ya que no poder
hacerlo al nivel que lo estaba haciendo
me ponía triste
entonces bueno como siempre
como siempre me gustó mucho el deporte
decidí seguir practicando otros deportes
que me podía permitir en ese momento la
rodilla hice boxeo escalada motocross
atletismo natación cualquier deporte que
me decían si quería practicar decía que
sí
una época en la que estuve visitando a
bombero
fue
fueron unos años muy sacrificados
pero muy gratificantes aprendí muchísimo
y ahora me sirve para decirle a los
niños cuando vean los cuales a las
charlas que si tienes bomberos lo que
tiene que hacer es estudiar es las
pruebas físicas al final saben pero el
temario es muy muy muy extenso
no lo conseguí y decidí seguir los pasos
de mi padre decidí ser militar en la
primera foto
de la jura de bandera es el día más
importante a nivel profesional de
cualquier militar fue muy muy emotivo
la siguiente foto es de una marcha que
hice
el período de instrucción dura cuatro
meses y fueron los cuatro meses más
divertidos de toda mi vida
la última foto es algo con la mochila la
que llevamos en la marcha esa marcha fue
de 25 kilómetros con la mochila que pesa
entre unos 25 y 30 kilos pero bueno yo
siempre iba muy contenta
para mí me de maniobras era de
vacaciones
pero un día en el trabajo estábamos
corriendo allí corríamos todos los días
mínimo 10 km
y empecé a notar muchísimo dolor en la
rodilla izquierda
fue el primer día que tuve que decir no
puedo
se acercó un compañero y dijo me siento
primero la soldado fernández no puede
seguir
nos dijo no os preocupéis volver andando
llegamos al cuartel andando para vamos a
comer y cuando nos queremos volver
cuando me quiero volver a poner en
marcha
no puedo plantar la pierna me duele
muchísimo se había inflamado y no podía
estirar y doblar la rodilla
me dijeron que medían que operar y
cuando salgo de quirófano me dicen que
ya no puedo hacer deporte que las
rodillas están muy mal
no me lo creo estoy siempre en la
habitación y en estos 6 meses yo seguía
intentando salir a correr aunque me
habían dicho que no podía pero como no
me creía que era verdad salía a correr
el primer día aguantaba 10 minutos tenía
que parar porque me dolía al día
siguiente volvía a salir solo aguantaba
7 no me rendía y al día siguiente volvía
a salir sólo aguantaba 5 hasta que al
final no no podía correr mi sinte
diferentes traumatólogos todos me decían
lo mismo el mismo diagnóstico
y decidí ir a una clínica especializada
en rodilla en madrid
en la cual me dijeron que evidentemente
todo lo que me habían dicho era verdad
que la lesión es degenerativa e
irreversible por lo tanto no se puede
curar y va a ir a peor
fue el día 4 de enero del 2017 cuando
comencé a ser consciente de mi lesión
aquí fue donde empezó el mes malo
el mes en que la gente me preguntaba qué
tal y yo lloraba
en el que no sabía cómo iba a afrontar
mi vida no podía hacer deporte que es lo
que me apasiona no podía hacer mi
trabajo porque no podía colgar me la
mochila y andar no podía ir al campo no
podía correr saltar
pero
cuando pasó ese mes en el que ya lo
asimilé decidí buscar alternativas
llame a un amigo que trabaja en hospital
nacional de parapléjicos le conté la
situación y me dijo si vas a hacer
deporte
él me introdujo en el deporte adaptado
empecé jugando al baloncesto en silla de
ruedas la primera foto es de los
primeros días en los que yo me senté en
una silla no tiene ni idea estaba más
tiempo en el suelo que
que jugando pero no me rendí y la
siguiente foto soy yo jugando en un
equipo de segunda división nacional
esta es una de las puertas que la
lección me ha abierto yo nunca había
practicado un deporte de equipo y la
lesión me ha permitido probar el balón
presencia de ruedas
he aprendido a que no comen los deportes
individuales que lo que yo entrenarse
una entrenarse solo me perjudicaba a mí
sino que aquí hay un compromiso y si
algún compañero faltaba perjudicaba a
todo el equipo también aprendí que no
siempre tienes que hacer el trabajo
bonito yo casi nunca tiraba canasta no
se me daba bien mi trabajo era defender
y abrir huecos para que una persona con
mejor tiro es más grande marcase puntos
pero sin el trabajo que yo hacía era
difícil que marcasen puntos
fui alternando el baloncesto con el
ciclismo adaptado
empecé en una hand bike en la que iba de
rodillas en la que se veía todo muy bien
veía perfectamente las curvas los
agujeros pero la lesión empeoró y tuve
que cambiarme una hand bike como la
primera foto en la que tumbada a esa
altura por aquí más o menos no se ve
nada nos veis si hay una grieta en la
carretera hacia dónde es la siguiente
curva y también me demostró lo
sacrificado que es el ciclismo no lo
sabía hasta ese momento
hasta que encontré mi sitio
volvía al kárate a mi deporte estaba un
día tomando una cocacola con mi hermana
en una terraza y me crucé con álvaro y
actual entrenador que sale en la primera
foto de espaldas y ex compañero de
tatami lo primero que me pregunto cuando
me vio fue que me había pasado
evidentemente y lo segundo que me dijo
fue que me estaba viendo en las redes
sociales haciendo baloncesto ciclismo
natación que porque no hacía karate el
deporte con el que yo he crecido con el
que me he formado y yo ignorante le
pregunté pero se puede
su respuesta fue rotunda si se puede
se fue un sábado o un domingo y el lunes
ya estábamos entrenando 4 horas
cuatro horas porque a nivel nacional no
hay nadie en mi categoría era la primera
persona en españa que va a participar en
competiciones de karate en silla de
ruedas
entonces nos tenemos que marcar
objetivos internacionales como era un
europeo
o el mundial que se celebraba en 4 o 5
meses después de esta conversación
empecé a entrenar en julio del 2018
y para octubre del 2018 me presento a la
liga nacional celebrada en ávila
hay donde ella me ve el presidente de la
asociación española de karate la
seleccionadora de para karate y me
comunican
que voy a representar a españa en el
mundial que se celebra en madrid en
noviembre imaginaros mi sorpresa cuando
con tan solo tres meses y medio de
entrenamiento me convocan para un
mundial no me lo creía
esta es otra de las puertas que me ha
abierto la lección puede ir a un
campeonato del mundo
esta foto desde las semifinales
ese día me desperté muy muy muy nerviosa
era mi primera competición internacional
no pude ni desayunar
pero cuando llegue al polideportivo y me
puse el karate que es el traje que
llevamos para competir se me pasaron un
poco los nervios no del todo y la
tranquilidad de haberlo dado todo
entrenando no había faltado ni un solo
día a entrenar lo había dado todo lo que
tenía en todos los entrenamientos y
saliese lo que saliese estaba tranquila
porque había hecho todo lo posible por
que saliese bien
las dos siguientes fotos son de momento
justo después de que digan por megafonía
que voy a pasar a disputar la final que
voy a luchar por el oro
según lo dijeron yo estaba de espaldas a
mi entrenador me giré y nos pusimos los
dos a llorar
y no ya sólo por ganar también seguirá
por todas las horas de trabajo que hay
detrás
los días que solamente he podido dormir
cuatro horas porque tengo mucho dolor en
las piernas y no puedo descansar pero a
las nueve que están entrenando los días
que tengan pollas en las manos de llegar
a la silla nos vendamos y seguimos los
días que tengo fiebre por alguna
infección
no es faltado ni un solo día
salga mejor o salga peor lanzamiento
pero ahí estábamos y estábamos los dos
él ha sufrido lo mismo que yo más
la siguiente foto es de minutos antes de
salir a
a disputar el oro álvaro que me conoce
muy bien aunque aparentemente yo estaba
tranquila
para nada estaba súper nerviosa él se
agachó y me dijo tranquila todo el
trabajo ya está hecho sólo por llegar
hasta aquí ya has ganado sal y disfruta
y esas palabras sal y disfruta fueron
las que a mí realmente me tranquilizaron
y eso hice
salí a hacer lo que me gusta salir a
hacer karate salí a hacer lo que llevaba
cuatro meses y medio preparando
imaginaros el vicente en el palacio de
deportes lleno de gente el ruido que
ello conlleva
salía al tatami se hizo el silencio
nadie hablaba ya sólo estaban los
árbitros y yo
dice sunshine ahora os pondré un cachito
y lo disfruté como nunca había
disfrutado haciendo un kata
la siguiente diapositiva del podium
viviendo un sueño
creo que para cualquier deportista es un
sueño subir al pódium y que suene el
himno de su país por él porque porque él
ha ganado
otra de las puertas que la lección me ha
abierto poder vivir un momento tan
inolvidable como este
es una foto del equipo nacional de cara
a ti para karate se consiguieron
bastantes medallas pero quiero destacar
las que consigue el para karate fuimos
primeros en el medallero mundial
con cuatro medallas de seis
participantes que íbamos cuatro
conseguimos medallas
el pódium de discapacidad intelectual
masculina fue entero de españoles
primero segundo y tercer puesto son
compañeros que están en esta foto en
discapacidad intelectual femenina la
chica que dos está el compañero que iba
en discapacidad intelectual quedó cuarto
del mundo y bueno luego muy medalla
este es el capataz en la final y cata de
la victoria
en el que vais a poder ver los elementos
de dificultad que os he explicado
anteriormente
al principio me costó mucho manejar la
silla en las primeras técnicas ya que al
pegar fuerte la silla gira
ahí está el primero
el caballito y ciro
y lo que más me gusta de este deporte
es el respeto
y la humildad siempre antes de empezar y
siempre cuando terminamos saludamos
tanto a los jueces como a los
adversarios muchas gracias por vuestra
atención y nunca dejéis de luchar por
vuestros sueños
[Aplausos]